hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game that was also played in
the Bilbao masters 2012 yesterday have
you've seen a game where Khurana had the
white pieces
he played also against Magnus Carlsen
but that was a game from round one of
that event this is a game from round six
of that event as we've already mentioned
it's a double round-robin and in the
previous game cousin played the French
defense against Caruana and it will be
very interesting because in this game
Caruana will play the fringe defense
against Coulson but before we check out
the game we do have to figure out what
color was Colin suit in the previous
video now in the previous video I've
shown you this photo and asked you what
color is this suit I said that okay it's
it's a red brownish suit but surely he
has some sophisticated color and a lot
of you really chipped in with your which
are very nice comments so let's check
out some of those comments and solve
this mystery of the suit color so as you
can see there are a lot of comments on
this topic when you see that Magnus is
wearing almost the same color as a
matter in this video not really
regarding well solving the mystery but
also a very nice comment then mr. mr.
vibe of a grovyle says I guess the
colour of course and suit is maroon so
maroon is one of the one of the answers
mr. arrow ghost also mentioned something
about the boat model not really sure
what the story behind it is but he does
say the suit colour Carson wears looks
like dried out blood Burgundy if I'm not
mistaken
normally I were black and dark blue but
those are the standard a blazer colors I
wear then mr. Levine she says GM been
fine gold says opposite colors are not a
draw if there are both rooks in the game
I'm mentioning probably about the
opposite color bishop same game that was
present in the previous video but also a
very nice coming that we're gonna use in
this video as well and then we have
Jimmy Air wold the fancy color you are
looking for is burgundy so we have
burgundy and maroon 4 for now Marcus
says that I guess the color of his suit
is called a maroon color is maroon by
MHD Shakur and then yaki a llama says
I'm not a color expert but I would like
to think that it is a dark wine color
suit then mister
tank tank killer says that the caller of
course in suit is actually a tall 8012
and while this is a very professional
answer it doesn't really help us solve
with the answer but also he mentioned
that it is a mix of three colors red
pair chili oil and spice apple in other
words the color is as indefinable as
Carson's opening sometimes then we have
the suit looks like a plum color then I
guess you could call that color Bordeaux
also this is a new suggestion to be
bored oh that's a wine color suit then
we have a comment by Leroy Jenkins the
name of the red brown color is burgundy
and then we have Neeraj Desai's says
that burgundy colored suit applies in
France known for its wine which has a
specific color known as burgundy vast
knowledge of sorts but then mr draught
centric answers that the color was named
after the wine which is derived from the
red brown grape skins that was the
predominant variety in the Burgundy
region not all Burgundy wines have a
burgundy color some are white and pink
so also this discussion about the suits
also brought us this very nice
discussion about vine varieties in
Burgundy so there you have it it's
either burgundy maroon or Bordeaux or
something in between but now our vast
knowledge of colors has definitely been
expanded but okay without further ado
Carson in this game has the white pieces
it's a game from round six and he opens
with E for we have E six like we said
constantly the differentiy fence against
core 1 and core wanna also plays the
French against Carlsen here and now we
have d3 a very rare reply to the
friendship which is the Kings Indian
attack against the French and okay call
it Quran I immediately challenges the
center we have d5 and mountain Knights
to d2 nice to f6 Knight the G to f3
Knight to c6 and now C 3 we have Bishop
to d6 exchanging in the center doesn't
really give you anything it's just a
meaningless exchange so we're not gonna
go into that Bishop to d6 and now Bishop
to e2 we have castles castles by Qasim
as well and now a5 and not allowing
white the
expanding on the queenside and cousin go
to rook to e1 develops the rook and now
we'll prepare to develop this light
square bishop somehow differently as he
did already play this pawn on d3 so you
can't really push it all the way most
likely he will play something like g3
and then fianchetto the bishop via F 1
and G 2 e v e5 is a very committal move
it's not easy to define a useful move
for black so you do have to develop the
light square bishop somehow you do have
to develop the Queen and you do have to
connect your works so Khurana decides to
change the structure the pawn structure
and the the character of the game by by
changing this formation in the center C
5 we have each capture some d5 by
Carlsen Knight captures on d5 and now
Knight to c4 by Carlsen
which is a very nice square for the
knight as it can't really be moved from
there if you try to kick it away with b5
you white will always capture on b6 and
then it's questionable if this
advancement on the Queen side is
favorable for black so instead after
this Knight to c4 move we have rook to
e8 and the cosine replies with Bishop to
f1 now the rook is also controlling D
file but now as corona displayed is to
be able to develop further a Bishop to
g4 now developing the bishop also comes
at the right moment as Carson did play
Bishop to f1 so now the knight is
definitely pinned h3 questioning the
whereabouts of this future whereabouts
of this bishop immediately does Khurana
want the capture on f3 not likely if
captures and Queen captures then also
your D Knight and b5 is attacked you
have to take care of that so first
bishop to h5 and here G 3G 4 also seems
possible but it would be too much draft
around the White King you know for good
taste we have nice to b6 here corona
questions crossings Knight and c4 but
the problem now is if you capture on d6
then the Queen can also capture on d6 so
here car across and takes a very
important decision and he decides to
capture the knight on bees
we have night captures pawn captures and
here Bishop to g2 fingering this Bishop
and now if you look at this position the
material on the board is still pretty
much equal but one thing you do have not
pretty much it's exactly equal but one
thing you do have to realize is that
because of these doubled pawns White's
pawn structure is better but it's far
too early in the game to take advantage
of such a weakness but if you imagine
that all of the pieces are of the board
so all of the pieces the ropes the
queens and you imagine only the pawns
are here then white if white would for
example play a four then this one a pawn
could control black's entire Queen side
and this is a very important thing to
notice but we're gonna get back to that
sometimes later
so b5 he wants to be able to meet a four
as if white gets a four in immediately
then like we said this pawn will control
the entire black Queen side we have b5
and now a four nonetheless
but now karana has b4 we have Bishop to
e3 cousin develops a piece Bishop to c7
and now comes Queen to b3 and this Queen
to b3 is also a very nice move because
well your opponent d3 is somewhat weak
and it's hard to do anything about it
but developing the Queen to b3 is very
nice because well it's a question can
you capture on d3 and you have to figure
out a lot of moves for example if Queen
captures on d3 then rook a to be one and
now what do you do with the Queen where
well you have a couple of options if you
go Queen to a 6 then this Bishop to f1
is a very unpleasant move the Queen has
nowhere to go you have to play b5 and
then well after this in-between move of
g4 bishop moves and now a captures on b5
I will win you the game as this attacks
both the Queen and the knight on the
other hand after Queen captures on b3
and rook a to d1 you could also go to g6
but then g4 simply traps the bishop on
h5 very unfortunate and while you can
capture two points for your Bishop it
will not be all that impressive white
will have a very nice development and
well what your two points will not mean
all that much
also after located the one you could
also go here but then simply in night 2
H 4 wins the Queen as now the night
removes both f5 and g6 from the black
Queen so there's really nowhere to go
and lastly but not leastly Queen to f5
of course of course runs into g4 again
winning the bishop and while you can
still give give up the bishop for two
pawns it will not be all that impressive
so Queen to b3 a very nice move very
nicely calculated that the the d3 point
is you know well off the table it's
actually on the table but it's off the
table if you know it's it's a funny
expression to use in chess it would seem
how about ok h6 and now comes Queen to C
for now the D pawn is protected as black
just made room for his queen on h7 if
the d3 pawn would ever be captured but
okay Bishop be captures on c3 here
capturing the pawn karana comes with
this very nice idea of a temporary pawn
sacrifice and you'll see what what he
meant by this B captures on c3b captures
and c3 and now
efore challenging this knight on f3
Carlsen captures we have D captures on
e4 and now comes Bishop captures on f3
special characters on f3 and Mountain
Knight to e5 so this is all very first
variation only move for Carson is Queen
to e2 you do have to protect your bishop
on f3 also your Queen on c4 is under
attack
so Queen to e2 bisher and Knight
captures on f3 Queen captures on f3 and
now comes Queen to d3 with an attack
against this week c3 pawn and also there
is now a double attack against the e4
pawn as the rook is also attacking it
you would be able to solve all of your
problems with Bishop to d4 but
unfortunately your queen is hanging now
so this is not possible
so first car someplace King to g2 now
Bishop to d4 is definitely a big threat
as a white would save his pawn and be up
a pawn but Khurana doesn't allow it
we have Queen captures on e4 and now
rush up to D for improving the position
of the bishop and also protecting the
pawn and c3 here
you can to give up the Queen for two
rocks if just in case any of you are
wondering because after captures
captures and Queen captures on b7 I
bought the rook and the bishop are under
attack and now black would also lose the
bishop so a queen and the bishop are is
much stronger than two rooks obviously
so after Bishop to d4 we have Queen
captures on f3 King captures on f3 and
now comes b6 and now if you look at this
position you can see that the material
is completely equal you can also see
that Carson's bishop on d4 is somewhat
more active than kuranes bishop on c7
also crosses King is a lot more active
on f3 and karana skin gun g8 but the one
very important thing you have to realize
is that both players have a dark square
Bishop and caranas pawns on the Queen
side are on dark squares which makes
them a target while Carlsen spawn
although they are isolated pawns cousins
a four point is on a light Square and
his pawn from light square is blockading
both of Coronas dark square pawns
so while corona spawns or targets across
ins a four point not so much and the
Bishop and pawn are complementing each
other pretty well here so a small
advantage for cousin and it will be very
interesting to see what he does about
this if you capture the rook and the
rook captures exchanging one pair of
ropes and go something like rook to be
one to challenge this b6 pond and rook
to e6 will defend it
so instead across and doesn't bother
himself with this he goes rook a to be
one challenges the b6 pawn immediately
and now comes route eight to c8 and
active defense and now if you capture on
b6 you have to go into this rook
captures anyone but of course it doesn't
work as it loses you the game captures
and now you've just blundered a piece
so after rook a to ca by karana we have
rook to e4 and now the rock on e4 is
obviously well protected
g6 and here we have if instead of this
g6 move you try something else there's a
well you don't really gain anything by
exchanging here you just improve the
position of the White King so g6
preparing f5 and now we have G
or you for a very interesting move
because if you play Bishop captors and
v6 this this is actually a variation
that ends in a in a force the draw
because after rook captures King
captures and rook to b8 pinning the
bishop then you have Bishop captures on
c7 a real capture some b1 and Bishop
captures an a5
so Carson would end up with two pawns
extra but he would have he wouldn't be
down the exchange now but still after f5
King goes up the board and now you will
attack da for pawn which now is a
weakness as it's on a white square in
the route can attack it you will start
to push your phone and now rook captures
on a4 we have Bishop to D to getting the
bishop out of the way but now look to a
to attacking the bishop again Bishop
captures on h6 but now comes the rook
captures on f2 and here neither side
will be able to win this because after
white starts pushing his pawn black will
simply approach with the King a bush up
to g5 create a wall against the black
king but now simply a rope to c2 and the
pawn isn't going anywhere
King d6 you will simply control the C
file if you push C seven then rook to be
to check will simply continue checking
the King and if you're tracking to e6
okay you can go
rook to e3 with check but you will
simply go back to c3 and again control
the C pawn so it would be a force to
draw it would seem if Bishop captures
and b6 is played here but such ideas are
definitely possible maybe in the future
so you know black has to keep an eye on
this g4 by Carlsen are still keeping
everything all of his options open you
know just perhaps improving the position
came to f8 and now comes h4
we have rook captures only for King
captures on e4 and now comes a rook to
e8 with check King back to D 3 and now
rook to e6 defending the b6 pawn as it
is attacked twice
we have Bishop to e3 attacking the h6
pawn Kings the g7 defending and now
comes Luke to b5 so little by little
cousin is improving the position of his
pieces and gaining more activity brush
up to d8 karana attacks the h4 pawn
here we have 85 and here rook the d6
with check if G captures an h5 den rook
captures on h5 and here black would just
have created more targets Carson has
these very nice pawns on light horse
while caranas b6 pawn and the dh6 pawn
are in dark scores which make them a
target for for both the bishop and
cousins rook
so instead after h5 we have looked a d6
check Carson goes
King to c4 and now comes over look to c6
width check King to d5 attacking the
rook and now comes rook back to e6 if
you play rook captures on c3 then Bishop
captures on b6 is not what you would
play but rather go to d4 check you would
win the rook and the game I hope I
didn't trick you too much there so after
Kings to d5 look to e6 not allowing the
king to approach and also defending the
rook push up the d4 check we have King
to f8 and now comes f4 so again a little
by little across and is pushing forward
you know if you just continue pushing
your pawns forward eventually they will
reach the last rank and will be promoted
to a queen Bishop to c7 attacking the f4
point and now even f5 attacking both the
g6 pawn twice ended the rook rook the d6
check King moves three four and now
comes rope to c6 and here rook to be one
here Carlsen doesn't gain anything by
capturing here first he wants to prepare
and bring this rook over to h1 because
after the exchange on g6 happens then
this h6 point will become weak as the
bishop is covering this dark square
diagonal very nicely we have king to e8
and now comes H captures ng 6f captures
and g6 and not rook to h1 attacking the
h6 pawn and now there's a problem if you
play g5 then f6 wins you the game as now
it blocks off the Rogues defense of the
h6 pawn white will simply capture it and
it will be over very quickly on the
other hand if instead of this route of
this g5 you play but captures on f5 then
G captures on f5 Bishop to d8 preventing
f6 but you don't really prevent f6
because white will simply push f6 and
now of course if you
captured in comes row captures on h6 and
it's a double attack against your bishop
in f7 but this simply you know trades
everything into a winning game game
simply king c6 captures captures and you
will promote either pawns
so after rook to h1 we have King to f7
but Caruana and now of course here if
you play something like a king to defy
was played but you can't capture
immediately if you capture immediately
then G captures a knife I would check
would of course lose you an entire row
after row captures on h6 so after King
to f7 we have Kings to d5 attacking
kuranes rockin c6 and now comes rope to
d6 with check king c4 and now G captures
on f5g captures on f5 and Bishop to d8
so we have f6 and here there's really
not a lot of things you can do with
black rook captures on h6 is a threat if
King to g6 then you get rook to g1 check
King f7 and rook to g7 check King to e6
and rook to h7 now the rook will win dh6
pawn only from from behind
so after f6 we have Bishop captures on
f6 but now it's not immediately a
disaster because after rook captures on
age sex which was played in the game the
rookies honor darks were not on a light
square like in the previous variation so
you can defend it with Bishop to e7 this
was playing game but still rope captures
Bishop captures and now comes King to b5
and now of course you will lose the
pawns but still Corona we'll try we'll
try to be tricky we have King to e6
Bishop captures now comes King to d7 and
now c4 King to see it we have Bishop
captures on a5 King to b7 and here is a
perfect moment for you to blunder the
entire game you are up to pawns but it
would be very easy to throw this game if
you play something like c5 for those of
you who would play c5 here you know
better to see it here and not play it in
a serious game because you will be very
sorry after the game our for those who
are maybe new to chess or new to this
channel we're just gonna show why this
doesn't work because black can simply
sacrifice his final piece here and after
King captures on C
five years you are up a piece and up
upon but it's the wrong piece and the
wrong pawn is the black king can simply
occupy a light square in the corner and
well you will not be able to kick the
King out of his cozy white square and
because you have a dark square bishop
and you will not be able to promote your
pawn
one such variation might go but up to c3
preparing to push the pawn black will
simply move the King back and forth and
after you start pushing your passed pawn
a 68 now you run out of moves because
you can either push a 7 and now it's a
stalemate the black King has nowhere to
go or you can simply move the bishop but
you can't play something like Bishop to
e5 it will still be stalemate and
whatever you play black will simply move
the King back and forth and you will
never never be able to kick it away from
the light square because you have a dark
square Bishop so after King to b7 you
have to be careful not to blunder it
like this so Bishop to b4 scolson wants
to exchange bishop score 1 of course
declines this Bishop 2 therefore we have
c5 and now it's okay to pull the C pawn
king to a7 c6 King to be 8 and now a5
King to a7 a 6 now a king to a 8 and now
Bishop to c5 Bishop back to be 8 and we
have kinked the c4 and now going the
other way
Bishop to c7 King 2ds King to d5 - up to
the 18th to east 6 but the c7 now comes
came to d7 and now a 5 again it would be
Khurana leaves the possibility of course
and maybe playing c7 which would again
result in a draw after Bishop capture
sinking captures the his King is already
very nicely occupying this 8 light
square but after Bishop to a5 cousin
simply played Bishop to e7 and here in
this position Caruana resigns in the
game so a very nice retaliation in the
second half of the tournament as it was
a double round-robin he reason because
now after you play something like King
a7 go after the a6 pawn bishop d8 will
win you the game you will either
exchange and then the C pawn will be
able to promote or we will move the
bishop for example the triple before and
then again c7 will win
game after captures and you will bring a
queen into the game and win easily
so yeah Bishop to e7
after this move unmoved 66 Fabiana
Caruana
resigned the game so yeah like we said a
very nice retaliation and I really do
hope you enjoyed that discussion about
colors and the grapes and the color of
wine in general in in Burgundy I thought
it was a very nice touch but also I do
hope you enjoyed this very nice game and
this very nice end game how even at such
a very young had such a very early
position let me just check Queen c4 well
maybe maybe even sooner how important
this was this this moment here of night
characters and b6 for example simply
because this a for was such a huge
threat and it really paralyzed Coronas
entire Queen side for the rest of the
game and later it was well used to a
maximum to be able to put this and gain
a full point so now I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank
Abdullah Pasha Michael Castagna Mario
Encino son Andrew spot Einstein and
Louise Gomez for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos you're thinking for
watching and I will see soon hopefully
with some more interesting content
perhaps we're gonna check up some other
previous and countries between Carson
Caruana as a warm-up for what comes on
Friday thank you all and I will see you
soon